See you, Weasel.
See you never.
Five minutes.
I know!
The colonel and the rest are alright.
Good.
Let's go.
Sorry I had to speed through the ending like that.
My goodness.
Oh, Weasel.
Ah!
Weasel.
I had nothing around me that I could believe in.
Not my parents, not anyone else.
That's why I joined the army.
It gave me a sense of right and wrong.
Lambda!
Thank you!
Of justice and purpose.
But that wasn't the right way.
Beliefs can't be borrowed.
They have to be looked for and thought about by yourself.
I have to face myself and start searching.
And I will find it.
That's good.
But if possible, maybe I could make that search with you at my side?
Yeah, I'd like that too.
Oh!
Really?
Really.
I came to Outer Heaven to settle a score with the past.
That was what I thought.
But that wasn't the truth.
I realized that when I met you, what I really wanted was death.
Wait.
When I met you, I just wanted to die.
What I wanted after everything, had been decided was for someone to take my life.
I must have been afraid.
Of seeing what was left standing.
Of myself as I really was.
Is that how you still feel?
No.
I think I want to live.
Accept myself.
Forgive myself.
Life is worth living.
Even if it hurts you.
Even if you hurt in it.
You taught me that.
You were my salvation.
Wow.
Snake.
That's why I've decided to go back.
Back?
To the States?
He was in Alaska.
He was still in the States.
Uh-huh.
Don't.
There's no way they'll let you go.
They'll be waiting for you.
And it's probably Foxhound.
I know that.
But I have to go back.
Why?
To understand.
Why we had to fight this fight.
What it was that I did.
And who Solid Snake was.
I'm going to confront the faceless men who Play chess with people's lives and hearts in the shadows.
So that I can understand.
And they will confess.
Every conspiracy they move.
Every victim left on the trail of their private gain.
Everything.
It's the only thing I can do.
For the casualties of theirs.
And my dirty war.
Snake.
Unless I do that, there will be no forgiveness.
And nothing to find for me.
Is that the end?
Don't worry.
I'm going back so that I can live.
When I've made them pay, I'll be back.
Will you wait for me?
You can count on it.
And...
That's Ghost Babble!
Thank you!
For the Akasupa.
Metal Gear Ghost Babble.
Hell yeah!
You can check out Bakutai in Zone of the Enders.
Yeah, I do want to play Zone of the Enders real bad.
Thank you guys.
I'm not going to let the VOD disappear.
So I'm just going to give a quick goodbye.
As we drive into the sunset.
Thank you!
I have not heard that Luka song.
I'll look it up.
Thank you!
Otsumito everybody!
Oh gosh, that took way, way longer than I expected it to.
But that's OK.
I still had a lot of fun.
And I hope you guys did as well.
Otsumito everyone, have a good night.
Have a good day.
And I'll see you guys when I see you next.
Bye bye!